joining us now New York Times
bestselling author of understanding
Trump former Speaker of the House Newt
Gingrich he also has a new online course
called defending America I know it's
long
I know it's drawn-out but everything I
said is true
you're laughing well no I'm just saying
the reason it has to be long is we have
never ever in American history had as
many different scandalous behaviors by a
president and his team as we are now
learning from Barack Obama and his team
this is an amazing hidden me when I look
at what Samantha power was doing by
itself
that's unbelievable why does the UN
ambassador have to unmask anybody and my
number one goal in this conversation is
to get across that the House and the
Senate have to open up serious in-depth
investigations they need to bring powers
in under oath and go through every
single unmasking why did you ask for
this what did you do with the
information what was the purpose of
doing it who else knew about it and then
they got to do the same thing with rice
and they order the same thing with the
attorney general Lynch and they got to
go right down the list and ultimately I
think they're gonna have to ask the
President Obama did all of this occur
and you didn't know it if you truly want
us to believe that the IRS the FBI the
Justice Department the NSA the State
Department the CIA all of these were
being used for illegal purposes and you
as president didn't notice it I think
it's astonishing I think you're exactly
right to take this length of time to
introduce appears it's amazing how the
elite media is avoiding bringing the
dots together and painting the picture
and they should be terrified I mean
every reporter in the country should be
frightened of the idea of the executive
branch of this government as powerful as
it is suddenly becoming lawless
and deciding is going to target
individuals and go after people mr.
speaker it's 24/7
everybody wants Paul Manafort indicted
it's it's like they want Paul but they
really want the president for them Paul
Manafort is just collateral damage
here's the issue that really bothers me
you're right about the Republicans
you're right these investigations
they're not happening though the Deputy
Attorney General didn't appoint a
special counsel here I don't know what
the Attorney General is doing Jeff
sessions but there is to me a sense of
okay if we're gonna go after Paul
Manafort and you gotta go after a thirty
year a career military person like
general Flynn maybe you need to go after
everybody else because the evidence
against Hillary alone the questions
about unmasking in surveillance leaks
alone
render a threat to the Fourth Amendment
to the Constitution and I don't see it
look I'm with you I don't mean Attorney
General Sessions did not recuse himself
from any of the things we're now
discussing he could he could instruct
the FBI to open up a case but at the
same time I would say to the House and
Senate and have been both parties by the
way I mean when you start seeing the
power of the FBI or the power of the CIA
being suborn for political reasons you
know whether you're a democrat or
republican you ought to be frightened
about the future of freedom in America
because we built very powerful
institutions to defend us from foreign
enemies and to defend us from criminals
and if those institutions start being
corrupted we are in deep trouble as a
country I've lost faith in all these
institutions ad the media to the lists
have you yes the truth is we're one of
the great crises in American history and
I think it's got to start the one place
you could imagine right this minute
aggressively digging into this is the
Congress I cannot understand why the
Republicans in the House and Senate are
not being dramatically more aggressive I
mean they're being hand
story after story after story that
proved that there was something really
sick in the Obama administration and
just general clapper who I've known for
years I have respected for years just
his behavior over the last year is
absolutely beyond me and he ought to be
brought back in and they ought to go
through step by step and I noticed that
he awarded things very carefully if you
go back to the part you kid
nobody in his particular institution but
I think that was an effect functionally
not being honest I sound very sounded
very Clintonian Mr Speaker we got a lot
more to get to